the latest on Kim and Kanye's newest
West and Khloe's growing bump Plus
Justin Timberlake keeps it real about
that wardrobe malfunction and has Jack
Antonoff moved on from Lena Dunham happy
hump day my people now yesterday Kim and
Kanye welcomed a baby girl into the
world and I asked you guys to help come
up with a name now there were actually a
lot of practical suggestions Kira threw
out haven West which I actually like but
I gotta give a shout out to Kathy Newman
for this quip I heard they named her
after her surrogate mother and called
her lip kit West Oh Cathy Cathy you
funny
I hurt my side a little bit but you know
Kim and Kanye haven't actually revealed
what they're calling their daughter yet
but expect an announcement soon with
their last two kids north and saint
names were not released until days after
each was born so we shall see et has
learned though that the new parents
quietly checked out of the hospital
yesterday just 24 hours after the
surrogate gave birth and now the baby is
at home today there's a beefed up
security at Kim --yes Calabasas compound
and a source tells us Kim Kanye north
and st. are enjoying every second of
bonding time with the new baby our
sources say Kris Jenner and Kim sisters
were at the hospital for the birth but
we don't know what that means
Kylie specifically youngest Jenner has
been m.i.a since sources said she is
also expecting a girl but today Kim
Instagram this heart-shaped bouquet from
Kylie and this pink rose covered cake
mom Kris gave her meanwhile the other
pregnant want Chloe she just revealed
how she was able to hide her buck from
the public for so long Chloe shared on
her app that it took some serious
strategy and a ton of courage her words
not mine but the two big ways she masked
her growing belly was the billowy coat
and clinched waist a line dresses like
the one she wore to Kim's baby shower
Clos also opened up about how she told
boyfriend Tristan Thompson she was
pregnant apparently he was already
suspecting something was up before she
even took the pregnancy test but when
she FaceTime to him with the happy news
thrilled quote I was nervous and he was
so excited I'm so blessed that Tristan
has been beyond supportive he's helped
me overcome any fear or anxiety that I
have switching gears now to the latest
Grammy performers who I'm sure will be
hit with some nerves of their own On
January 28th it was just announced that
Miley Cyrus will take the stage at New
York's Madison Square Garden with Elton
John to perform one of his classics and
other performers include Bruno Mars and
our girl cardi B Sam Smith and YouTube
now not expected this year Justin
Timberlake a source tells ET JT is busy
preparing for his halftime performance
at the Super Bowl the following week
Justin is also set to drop his next
single supplies tomorrow off his
upcoming album but apparently he's not
too busy to talk about that Janet
Jackson incident that played the last
time you performed at the Super Bowl in
a new interview with beats 1 radio the
36 year old admits he struggled through
the 2004 halftime show after Janet's now
infamous wardrobe malfunction and I
stumbled through it you know to be quite
honest like I had my wires crossed and
it's just something that you you have to
look back on and go like okay well you
know you can't change what's happened
but you know you can you can move
forward and learn from it and then you
and you and Jenna took some time to do
that after the fact and kind of resolve
the situation like we're able to make
peace of the whole thing absolutely yeah
yeah and I'm not sure that I don't know
that a lot of people know that Justin
goes on to say that conversation behind
the scenes with Janet happened because
he values the relationships he does have
with people well we shall see what
tricks he has up his sleeve for his
third appearance at the Super Bowl could
he bring out Janet Jackson you tell me I
for one think that would be a bold and
very gracious move by Justin given the
fallout for Janet after that whole thing
and the very fact that the time is up
hashtag justice for Janet meanwhile Jack
Antonoff is seeking some justice of his
own the bleachers frontman sick of the
rumors took to Twitter late Tuesday
night to shut down any speculation he's
already dating jack just ended his
five-year relationship with Lena Dunham
and made it clear he's
see anyone he tweeted I resent having
the most important friendships and
working relationships in my life
reduced to dumb heteronormative gossip
those relationships are deeply important
and sacred jack is seemingly referencing
rumors that a little something something
was going on with Lord he had produced
her second album melodrama but clearly
Antonov is not here for the gossip plus
he says he's single right now and would
prefer you don't reduce his friends and
business partners to
boyfriend-girlfriend BS and I say
respect alright guys that's it for today
thank you for watching and for
commenting we see you so keep the love
coming and I'll be back tomorrow with
another dose of daily Denny I'll see you
then I'm gonna go this